this week on brian ross investigates not
again
a new covert 19 variant sweeps the world
and seems poised to sweep across america
cases are being reported all over the
world now including among fully
vaccinated people but is it as scary as
first described when it showed up in
south africa
dr william shaffner is here to give us
the straight scoop
plus the big cheat a new book on donald
trump and his never-ending efforts to
pad his bank account unlike all his 44
successors donald trump walked into the
white house
trying to do everything he could to
enrich himself and his family
just how far did the president go
there was a photo op and donald trump
charged three dollars and fifteen cents
for each of the glasses of water that
were put on the table as props plus this
week's winners and losers in the media
see if you agree with the choices made
by the editors of mediaite
from the law and crime trial network
this is bryan ross investigates
good evening and thank you for joining
us and welcome to our friends on
facebook live i'm brian ross joined as
always by my colleague rhonda schwartz
and rhonda we begin with the
frankenstein monster that wasn't the
dire warnings about that new kovid
variant the omicron variant that tanked
the stock market and led to a near panic
by some over a killer variant that
couldn't be stopped rhonda
well now brian real reporting has
replaced the speculation and we've
learned the pfizer vaccine plus a
booster seems effective against this new
variant which is spreading more rapidly
but it early reports indicate the
effects are much less severe brian so to
get a reality check on all this we're
joined now by dr william schaffner from
vanderbilt university's medical school
and one of the country's leading experts
on infections thank you so much dr
schaffner for being here let me start by
asking you how do you categorize this
new variant we've told we've been told
it's so scary
uh well brian and ronda good to be with
you you know i don't certainly
characterize it as a frankenstein
variant
my fingers are crossed we've learned
certain things number one the pieces of
the puzzle are coming together yes it is
highly highly contagious probably more
contagious than our well-known enemy the
delta variant but number two
could it produce less severe disease
there are hints in that direction
but more data will be forthcoming it
certainly doesn't look as though it's
producing more severe disease and then
apropos of what rhonda has just told us
yes the early data do look as though our
current vaccines particularly with a
booster
really do provide noteworthy protection
against omicron so so far
not too bad but dr schafter the people
at pfizer is saying there may have to be
a fourth shot another booster is that
accurate
well you know the pfizer folks are
looking down the road we're not anywhere
near that yet but none of us would be
surprised if at some interval let's say
annually as we do with our flu shots we
would have to get a covered booster
along with it and as a matter of fact
there are now vaccine specialists those
scientists putting together flu vaccine
and covet vaccine so maybe we'll only
have to roll up one sleeve and get
protected annually against both flu and
covert dr schaffner question for you
from rhonda schwartz rhonda
is this ever going to end dr schaffner
or is this our new normal are we going
to be wearing mass and dealing with
variants for
is there going to be an end
uh rhonda i wish i could give you good
news but the reality is that covet is
now here with us in one form or another
and we'll be coping with it for the
indefinite future just as we do with
influenza the trick is to do so
effectively to keep the impact of covert
down for that
we'll all have to cooperate
getting vaccinated periodically i would
imagine
and on occasion
dusting off our masks and putting them
on again
that's not so hard if we could all do
this together
well that's a good question doctor if we
can all do this together to what extent
do you think the resistance the
hesitancy to get vaccinated the
anti-vaxx movement the anti-mass
movement has hurt the efforts to stop
this pandemic
well brian as you know i'm down here in
tennessee we're a substantially under
vaccinated state
and our state legislature has just
passed a series of laws that make public
health more difficult
i think the under vaccinated folks out
there the folks who still haven't
availed themselves of the first dose
they really have hampered the public
health response to covid we keep having
to work to try to persuade them to join
the rest of us and get vaccinated but
it's persuasion enough do you think the
mandate should be expanded
uh you know you and i have discussed
this before yes i'm actually in favor of
mandates if we're in a war against this
virus we've to date uh depended on a
volunteer army the people who
volunteered to be vaccinated but the
enemy has just gotten reinforced with
delta and now with omicron and uncle sam
now needs you we're going to draft you
into the army we're going to oblige you
to be vaccinated i don't think that's a
bad thing we've done it in history in
the past and i think mandates will work
to bring people in which is not to say
they're easy as you know they're hung up
in the courts now but i think it is the
best way
to getting this virus under control dr
schafter there's been no real evidence
of serious side effects but is there a
cumulative effect that could be for all
these boosters a cumulative effect that
we could suffer from having all these
different vaccines
the short answer is no you know we get
our tetanus boosters every year we get
flu shots every year we get other
vaccines periodically there really are
no
long-term adverse effects to these kinds
of immunizations
we wouldn't recommend them the world
health organization wouldn't recommend
them unless the world's scientific
community had agreed that they were safe
and let me ask you finally how are you
going to spend the holidays and what are
your recommendations for our viewers
about the holidays given this new
variant that's spreading so rapidly
well we have an extended family right
here in nashville we will all get
together we're all vaccinated and
boosted i would say that that should be
a requirement for everyone and then at
thanksgiving because we have a couple of
family members who are really at high
risk of complications we all got a rapid
test that morning we were all negative
so when we gathered together we could
take off our masks and relax and really
enjoy the occasion and i wish for
everyone a safe holiday season all right
dr william schaffner from vanderbilt
university thank you so much for joining
us here this evening always a pleasure
coming up next the big cheat a pulitzer
prize-winning investigative journalist
totals up the for-profit presidency of
donald trump you're watching brian ross
investigates on the law and crime trial
network
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live lawn
crime network with youtube tv for all of
your daily live trial coverage legal
news expert analysis and original true
crime programs subscribe to youtube tv
today and then locate law and crime in
the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle watch lawn crime every day with
youtube tv we put you in the jury box
it's now more than a year since donald
trump lost the election despite his
falsehoods to the contrary and at the
time we heard a lot about what crimes he
was going to be charged with and
prospects of the former president being
sent to prison rhonda
that's right yet none of this has
happened brian and mr trump continues to
exert his influence over the republican
party vowing revenge on those in the gop
who voted to impeach him and refuse to
support the crackpot theories that he
and his cadre of loyalists were pushing
brian
to get a better understanding of what's
happening in the world of donald trump
we're joined now by david k johnston
pulitzer prize winning
reporter and author of a nude book the
big cheat
how donald trump fleeced america and
enriched himself and his family david
thanks so much for joining us how did he
fleece america
well unlike all his 44 successors donald
trump walked into the white house
trying to do everything he could to
enrich himself and his family not just
while he was in office although he
intended to stay forever
but in the event he wasn't in office uh
afterward and we have uh what i've done
in this book has taken all these loose
threads you know it's a story in the
wall street journal something in the
washington post something at politico
and picked out things that show you the
pattern of what was going on by weaving
these loose threads into a tapestry
and he now faced criminal prosecution
lots of talk about that in the last year
or so since he lost the job but so far
no prosecution
no but i'm confident he's going to be
indicted in manhattan
among other jurisdictions what happened
in manhattan is donald fought to the
supreme court twice
to withhold business records
and lost of course when the records were
turned over it turned out there wasn't a
million pages there were five million
pages and the prosecutors have to
diligently go through all of those so
they aren't hit with a surprise at trial
as we've seen during the course of his
uh term in office uh foreign policy
domestic policy often seemed to be
intertwined with his own family's
financial interests
is that really what happened exactly
what happened brian one of the most
important examples of that was
uh jared kushner the first son-in-law
made a disastrous purchase of a building
666 fifth avenue just down the street
from trump tower he paid 1.8 billion
dollars nearly all of it borrowed and
within a couple of years it was worth
less than half that
so he went to the government of qatar
and tried to get an 800 million dollar
loan
cutter is home to our most important
military base in the middle east they
are a very crucial ally of us
the qataris looked at it and said we're
not going to do that we're not stupid
donald trump as president then turned on
the qataris
he called them horrible names he said
they were financing terrorists and he
aligned himself with the saudis and the
emiratis who are enemies of the qataris
and it's true that the qataris fund
terrorists to terrorist organizations
according to our state department while
the saudis fund about 60.
so
later
jared got bailed out by people from
saudi arabia and the emirates
and it's in one of a number of stories
of where our national security and our
national well-being were submarined by
the trump white house
for money
and can you actually show in your
reporting david that this was cause
effect or was it just a grand
coincidence uh it would be kind to call
it a grand coincidence i mean there's
there's no logical explanation for it
otherwise plus
the news just broke uh last week that
jared kushner now out of the white house
is using his connections in saudi arabia
and the emirates to raise money for him
to manage and invest
so i think the fact pattern is
overwhelmingly clear
as to what took place the motive in the
case of donald trump is he doesn't know
anything about the middle east he
doesn't know a sunni from a shia now i
don't expect most of the people in the
audience to know that but if you're the
president of the united states you damn
well better be very sophisticated about
divisions within the middle east
after he left office was he wealthier or
poorer than when he became president
well to be honest we don't really know
because as we learned from the
indictment of the trump organization for
tax fraud they keep two sets of books
donald is not a billionaire but he's not
a poor man he's clearly a wealthy man
he's just not a billionaire
yet in your book you describe example
after example of sort of like which
seems to be kind of a penny pitching
asking the government to pay for small
things yes
donald
did everything he could to get the
secret service and others to pay the
highest prices possible when shinzo abe
the prime minister of japan came to see
him at mar-a-lago
there was a photo op and donald trump
charged three dollars and fifteen cents
for each of the glasses of water that
were put on the table as props i have
the invoice
showing how thoroughly he made sure not
one penny that could be obtained was let
go
he charged for three dollars and fifteen
cents for each glass literally took the
time to do that yeah yes that's that's
how that shows you how diligent trump
told his staff to be
so if he's billing the government for
three dollars and fifteen cents for a
drinking class what does that say to you
about his overall wealth that's not what
a fabulously rich man does is it well
you know back in 1990 i revealed donald
wasn't a billionaire he couldn't pay his
uh vendors and uh when he told me he was
worth three billion dollars as we were
walking along in atlantic city i said i
don't believe you he said what do you
mean you don't believe me what's the
name what's the name of your editor and
i said well let me give you his phone
number
and you know
the conversation went to why don't you
believe me and i said donald i'm a
newspaper reporter with eight children
and i pay all my bills on time
you claim to be worth three billion
dollars and you can't pay your bills
david you've been following donald trump
now for well over a decade several
decades has it become an obsession with
you
no in fact uh i had plans to do
something entirely different i was
writing a very
slim book
laying out how we could have a much
better federal tax system a system that
every expert has looked at it says would
work when donald announced and i
realized he was serious this time he'd
announced before twice
and i felt knowing donald as well as i
have for more than 30 years i had a duty
to my country to tell people about who
donald trump is a lot of other people
have said nobody knows and understands
donald trump and his finances more than
i do and so all of this has been for me
a sense of duty trust me i really had
other things i plan to do since i'm past
retirement age
what was the last time you heard from
donald trump and what do you expect to
hear from him in the future
uh donald you know has called me so many
times at home i have no memory of the
number
the last time he called me was in april
of 2016
when i had asked him to respond to 21
questions about his
associations with criminals of various
kinds in different venues
and he called to once again yell at me
and threaten me and say he was going to
sue me as he's done many times and i
said well donald if you have a case sue
me
and um
he angrily hung up on that conversation
and i remember turning to
one of my grown children who was sitting
in the room and saying you know i'll bet
that's the last time donald ever speaks
to me
and it was it was the only he's
referenced me since then a couple of
times he's called me the journalist he
hates most in the world principally i
believe because he knows i have my stuff
down solid and he can't do anything but
yell he has no case against me and you
know he has a name for me he calls me
the weird dude so i took out the website
weirddude.net though i haven't done
anything with it yet
all right the weird dude thank you so
much david k johnson author of this new
book the big cheat how donald trump
fleeced america and enriched himself and
his family david thank you so much for
being with us here tonight thank you
brian
coming up next this week's winners and
losers in the media see if you agree
with the choices made by the editors of
mediaite
you're watching brian ross investigates
on the law and crime trial network
time now for this week's winners and
losers in the media as chosen by the
editors of meteorite and we're joined by
aidan mclaughlin who's the
editor-in-chief of mediaite which like
the law and crime trial network is part
of the dan abrams media empire and aiden
we begin with your first winner yamiche
alcindor a young woman a reporter on the
rise
that's right so yamiche alcindor is uh
pbs's washington correspondent and she
just got snapped up by nbc news um to
serve as their washington correspondent
and uh you know it's part of a a big
spree of hiring that nbc news has been
embarking on i'm sure you've noticed
over the last couple weeks they've
announced a series of big name hires
from other outlets they hired politico's
mark caputo who had been there for a
decade they also hired tom yamas from
abc news um so yamiche is just the
latest in this series of hires which is
all set towards
nbc news bolstering their streaming
platforms they announced earlier this
year that they were going to hire more
than 200 journalists
to work on those platforms as all the
networks sort of make this pivot towards
streaming
yamiche is one of the biggest hires
they've made yet but she really made a
name for herself in the white house
briefing rooms throughout the trump
presidency and now in joe biden's
administration as well um so it was a
big big win for nbc news and yamiche
alcindor so the big future for her then
yeah for sure yeah and i think you know
at nbc that's a bigger platform than pbs
um uh so i expect her to get a lot more
uh face time now uh both in the white
house and uh obviously on cable news and
on an nbc streaming platform
and for this week's uh loser chris cuomo
formerly of cnn
yeah chris cuomo uh as you know
brian has not been having a great couple
weeks uh he was fired by cnn last
weekend
got called up by jeff zucker who had
previously been a staunch defender chris
cuomo uh throughout his uh problems with
his relationship with his brother
and
fired him on saturday afternoon that
became public on saturday night
then harper's which was publishing his
book
announced that they were dropping it
so it was a double punch for chris cuomo
in the last couple days
he also announced that he was not doing
his serious xm show anymore so right now
he doesn't really have any other outlets
uh to speak out on except for his
twitter account um which is really you
know typically when when an anchor or a
host gets fired from their cable news
show they'll go to siriusxm and keep
that up or they'll go to other outlets
you know maybe host a podcast have a sub
stack something like that just to keep
up you know an audience but chris cuomo
is now without one so we'll see what
happens in the next couple weeks whether
he reemerges in some capacity but right
now it seems like what what he's going
to be doing is pursuing a pretty intense
legal fight uh with cnn
which said that they did not pay him
severance after he was fired he's
looking at six million dollars a year
according to reports and he has three
years or more left on his contract so
that's a big number that'll be a big
legal fight he's alleged essentially
that jeff zucker the head of cnn knew
all along what he was doing
right so he says that jeff sucker knew
all along that he was advising his
brother and he did this close over the
summer uh that he was not an advisor he
said to his brother but that he would
always give his brother advice right
that was the sort of language that he
used but we saw when the new york state
attorney general released their report
their massive report on into the
allegations against andrew cuomo the
former governor governor of new york
that chris corbin really had an almost
official uh
level of advice that he was giving he
was texting with andrew cuomo's team he
was using his journalistic sources to
find out information about when these
allegations were being published by news
outlets he really had a very formal um
role in advising his brother he was
really working with the team not just
advising his brother in sort of a
personal capacity um so i think that's
what really took jeff zuckerberg for
surprise and cnn's obviously going to
argue that they fired him for cause
and that he's not owed any severance but
as you say three years left on the
contract
chris cuomo we expect was going to be
suing for 18 million dollars he's hired
some very high profile lawyers to fight
his case cnn's going to be doing the
same so things could get pretty ugly now
in the next uh in the next couple months
indeed and as you know aiden uh chris
chrome was a former colleague of mine
when i was at abc news and i have been
filling in for him on sirius radio as
well so thank you so much for your
reporting again this week from media i
appreciate it very very much
and thanks to all of you for joining us
and thanks to our staff here for getting
us on the air and off the air every week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you